hey guys it is the Fed of October my
name is Justin you're watching gamespot
news + up today the ps4 trophies for
call of duty 4 remastered has been
revealed the 51 trophies encompassed the
game's original 37 achievements from
xbox 360 as well as some interesting new
additions one such edition is called
time paradox and there are spoilers
coming if you haven't played through
modern warfare time paradox is earned by
killing off Makarov the villain from
modern warfare 2 and 3 another new
achievement is called Doug's I hate dogs
which you can earn by killing 20 attack
dogs with a knife you can check out the
full list of achievements in our story
on site and modern warfare remastered is
playable from October fifth those of you
who have pre-ordered a premium version
of call of duty infinite warfare next up
Xbox co-creator Sheamus black Lee has
called the original xbox controller
embarrassingly enormous black Lee's
comments came in response to a Twitter
query over whether he could discuss the
gigantic controller likely replied
politically I had no juice to fix it
they ignored focus tests I understand
you can learn to helicopter on it he'd
previously told IgM the due to the fact
that the circuit board was the size of a
large dinner plate fitting it inside the
controller meant it was going to end up
being pretty bloody Lodge he went on to
say the dreamcast was our favorite
console at the time and it had a big
control of that dr. Tamagotchi so that
made it seem less insane finally a
Facebook advert seems to imply that
resident evil 7 SB armored will be
exclusive to PlayStation VR for 12
months the rosy 7 advert features small
text which reads resident evil 7
biohazard coming in 2017 and exclusive
to PlayStation VR for 12 months Capcom
me yet to announce that the VR
experience will be arriving on any other
platforms the VR supported beginning our
demo for resident evil 7 serves as a
standalone prologue to the main game and
will not be featured in the fall
capcom have since released other Rosie
seven demos called Twilight and lanterns
a ladder of which you can watch me and
doreen fearfully and feel asleep laying
on gamespot right now resident evil 7 is
drew out the ps4 xbox one and pc on
january 24 of next year that's
everything I've got for you today do
head to gamespot for stories on batman
arkham via and a new ps4 update and i'll
see you again tomorrow